[inaudible] but you know that government is all obsessed by sex and gender.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
The last budget,
you know,
that was a gender budget.
The,
the,
I think I would,
what does that even mean by that?
Meaning they didn't have a lot of economic data in the budget.
You supposed to be a budget,
supposed to have economy,
economic data,
and then have a lot of economic data.
But I think the word gender was in the budget to be on good times.
So,
and the F I will give you an example.
If you want to build a pipeline in Canada with the new bill c 69,
you need to do,
uh,
enter sectorial sex and gender analysis.
Don't ask me what that means and tell sexual,
sexual sectional sex and gender analysis that's in religious stations.
So the sex and gender to build a pipeline to build a pipeline.
A lot of people were talking about this when we were in Alberta,
the sex and gender expert.
We'll look at the impact of building a pipeline in a rural community with man
and woman and Desex.
And so it's crazy.
It's a nonsense.
It's crazy.
So,
and this government is obsessed about that.
And I think that's why people are looking for an alternative.
So,
so a guy like Trudeau,
it's hard to judge what's really going on in someone's mind.
But do you think he really believes in the things that he's saying when it comes
to all of this gender stuff?
Or is it just that it always leads to bigger government and what he wants
fundamentally is bigger government because he wants more power.
He believes in state power.
Yeah.
So,
so that it's almost like it's a,
it's an ends.
The ends justify the means.
It's like you'll just say anything about gender and all these things.
I think he probably kind of believed them,
but at the end they just give him more power.
I think first of all,
he believe it.
And I think also it's because he believed in a big government that will fix
every problem in our society.
Uh,
that's his philosophy.
And you know,
when he said that,
you know,
uh,
the Noaa Canada is no core identity or Canada is the first suppose national
state.
You know,
people that the,
the understanding Canada that we,
we are a nation.
We are all not the post nation state.
We are,
we have Canadian values and we share the western civilization values.
So for him is a little bit like his father,
you know,
uh,
the UN and the world is important and the mass immigration and open borders and
everybody,
everybody can come to Canada.
Uh,
that's what people,
they don't like that in Canada.
They want us to respect our immigration system and,
and having a sustainable immigration system.
So Trudeau adding wants to build a big government.
And at the end he believed in a supra and national government,
uh,
you know,
he,
uh,
he just signing in 2010,
with the UN,
there's the UN UN pa UN parliamentary assembly.
It's a,
it's a group that prolonged to promote a world government,
like the,
uh,
the EU parliament that will be able to,
write legislation that will be biding with and with the countries and they will
lost their sovereignty and to do in 2010,
uh,
promote that and believe in that.
So it's all about the UN.
It's not about the big government and that it's all about him trying to find the
right policies that will solve every problems.
But that's not the case.
Just less regulation,
more freedom.
You'll have more prosperity and then people are tired of that in Canada.
It almost strikes me as it's like a psychological condition more than anything
else.
It's just like sort of what,
like,
it's obvious to me that you believe in just that the individual can,
yeah.
To the best of their ability,
solve their problems,
not all of them,
but to the best of breed.
Absolutely.
And I think that this other set of people believe that,
I don't know.
I would view it as almost a very dim way of viewing humans.
That if we all weren't controlled,
that endless evil would spread everywhere or,
or something to that.
I think they believe that Canadians are children and you know,
most follow regulation and you,
but I trust,
you know,
I have faith in people I fade,
that they have the ability,
the dignity and the right to make their own decision and determine their own
destiny.
Uh,
that's important for us.
That's important for me.
And yes,
you can make,
you can make a mistake,
but you will be responsible of your success and your,
your,
your mistake if that's how you learn in a society.
Uh,
that's why,
you know,
uh,
speaking about that,
people like me a little bit and then they're looking at Jordan Peterson and the
single Bernie a personal responsibility.
And Jordan also is his book.
It's all about that,
you know,
clean your,
your,
uh,
your room before I,
before cleaning the,
the world is so,
so be responsible of your action.
And that's what we want to do.
And that's what,
as a politician,
I want to,
I want to do,
well,
I mentioned it before we sat down,
but I may as well say it on camera that when I go to these events and with
Jordan and especially in the 12 or 15 we did in Canada,
I say something about Trudeau and the whole audience boos,
I say talking about you and the whole audience goes crazy.
So,
so something good is happening.
Um,
you've mentioned,
uh,
borders a couple of times.
This does seem to now be the hot one,
at least in the United States,
where we seem to be caught between either a wall or open borders and it's such
a,
it's not a real choice.
I don't think.
It's not a sensible choice.
And in one hand,
if you're for the wall,
they say you're racist.
If you say you're for open borders,
then you're an anarchist or whatever it is.
So what would be the right way to look at borders if you want to maintain your
national sovereignty?
Yeah,
and that's the debate that we're having right now in Canada because as you know,
we have people who are crossing the border,
uh,
from the state of new or to Quebec.
And,
um,
the,
they are asking to do,
they said that they are refugees and actually down that really refugees,
you know what?
Your life is not in danger in the state of New York.
Uh,
but that being said,
I think it is.
They didn't proceed.
Proceed.
Yeah.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
the last two years,
I think more than 40,000 people cross the border illegally.
So the Trudeau government doesn't want to fix that.
And that's a big issue in Canada.
So,
uh,
what I'm asking as a politician,
we have an immigration system and that is it by it.
It was going very well at points system.
So it's a privilege to be Canadians and we want people who come here to share
our Canadian values are basic western civilization values and,
and it's a privilege.
So we have tree kind of immigrants in Canada,
the reunification of family,
the refugees and the economy can grow into a person that will come because they
have a job because the business wasn't able to find a Canadians for that job.
So they are coming,
they have a job and usually tease you or 20 greater society if you have a job.
But we don't need to build a wall between Canada and us.
We just need to be sure to respect our immigration system.
And the way to do that,
it's to have a discussion with president Trump about the third safe country
agreement.
We had a,
we have an agreement with us about that and to fix that loophole.
So people who are crossing at a real point of entry,
it's all okay what people who are crossing and not a real point of entry.
Uh,
we in the end,
my school bag to the u s and we must have an agreement with the US about that.
And I think we can have that kind of argument if we sit with the Trump
administration.
But at the same time,
we must be clear that people who are coming to Canada must come from the right
reason.
And these people who are crossing our border,
uh,
right now,
40% of them will have to be the port because they're not real refugees.
So it's a big cost for Canadian taxpayers because these people will be deported
maybe in two years from now.
So we must fix that.
And we have a strong position.
Our platform,
yes,
we'll fix that at the border.
What we need,
don't need to impose a wall.
We don't need to create a war.
But the most important,
and we need to focus on more economy can be grounds.
That's what we need in Canada.
And a little bit less of refugees.
And other debit less of reunification of family.
So that's a strong position.
But seeing that,
uh,
yes,
it's a risk in Canada when they see that as a politician.
Um,
but I'm taking that risk and uh,
yeah.
What,
what do you make of the libertarian argument that is pro open border?
Because I've had many guests are that are libertarian that take that position.
I've never been convinced of it.
I actually,
I just,
I don't understand the fundamental premise because as you said earlier,
it's,
if you're a nation,
a nation has borders.
That's just otherwise everything is just in a morphous blob.
But what I'm sure you hear this very libertarian circles,
so what do you make of that argument that's not coming from the left that's
coming from [inaudible] yeah,
absolutely.
So all party is,
we're not anti immigration and we're not open borders for immigration.
So what do we want?
It's a little bit less immigrant,
250,000 a year.
Like we had under Stephen Harper,
not 350,000 a year to do increase in,
to do a government.
The increase that by uh,
um,
uh,
40%.
So what I'm saying,
when people say,
oh,
well,
you know,
open border is good.
It's not,
it's not to everybody that can be part of a nation if you don't support of
values.
If you are,
I don't know,
pro uh,
sharia law,
that's against our values.
That's again,
freedom between men and woman.
Equality between men and woman are the respect of the rule of law.
If you want to impose a new rule of law or Sharia law,
uh,
the integration one be very well in our society.
So these people,
uh,
much they,
they must share our values,
our western civilization values.
So that's why if you have an open border and you want everybody from everywhere
to come to Canada,
that will create tension and dislike in the population.
And that's happening actually in Europe actually right now.
Are you able to point to that?
That's the one thing that I've never understood that Europe has.
Having all of these integration problems.
Merkel has basically said she screwed up.
Yeah.
You know,
after letting a million people in,
are you able to point to that?
And say,
you see they might have,
that's the warning I'm doing that.
You know John,
his son,
I'm telling,
I'm telling me maximi nothing happened in Canada.
It's a great country.
I said,
yes it is a great country,
but our one this country to be like that in 20 years from now.
So that's why we must have the discussion right now and people who are coming to
Canada much more share our values.
If not,
you know,
they're not welcome because the integration will be very difficult.
And that's,
that's the total government policy on extremely particular tourism.
So you know,
for [inaudible] diversity is our strength is friend.
And for me it's unity.
When we Zahra Strand as a country and by two it always,
always pushing for more diversity,
more diversity,
more diversity.
And I said that and I tweet about that more diversity.
What else?
Our country it at the end it will destroy our country.
I know that we,
there's Canada is a diverse country with people coming from different countries
and with different culture.
But at the end,
the integrated our society because they believe in our freedom,
in our values.
In a,
and they want to share our traditions and our irritated celebrate are irritated.
So that's what we want and we need to have that discussion in Canada.
And,
and I think that discussion actually,
so that's why I don't believe in open borders.
I think it will create a tomb much diversity.
And I want people who come in our country to share our values and it's a
privilege to be Canadians and uh,
uh,
like it's a privilege to be an American.
So we must choose are immigrants.
And we did that for the last 35 years and that was very successful for our
country and people,
it's interesting,
you're only trying to roll it back to what it was 40% less.
I mean,
it's not like you're doing something,
it's not like you're saying,
we're not letting anyone else 100 people that are coming and it's going back to,
you know,
it's a couple years ago.
Yeah.
And it is just stay until the door is radical.
Because the last Paul in Canada,
49% of Canadians said that they want fewer immigrants and only 6%,
6% of Canadian said that he wanted more immigrants.
So who is the radical Nixon,
Bernie or just thing to do?
It's just central to increase that by 40%.
So that's a fact.
And,
and that's what Canadian itin they're fed up with.
It's extremely,
extremely good tourism.
Uh,
the cold of diversity,
uh,
you know,
it too much.
It's too much.
And I think Canadian can see that in the future.
If you go on,
on,
on that road,
we'll have more problem and the integration would be more difficult.
And,
uh,
but [inaudible] team immigrants and people came in our country and the build
this country,
so,
and,
but they came for the right reason and they're proud to be Canadians,
but the liberals and,
and the conservative are doing identity politics and they tried to please have
risk per Sharle enter as good,
but every special ethnic groups also,
so,
you know,
and they call that outreach.
Um,
but for me,
the policies must be the same for every Canadians.
And we don't do any difference with your race,
your gender or what.
So for us it is not important,
but the Kenyan government is playing like this,
being that,
that,
uh,
that the,
they're doing these policies and I think that won't,
that won't be good at the end for our country.
Yeah.
So speaking of these policies,
I've also seen you on Twitter.
You're not a big fan of what's going on at the UN these days.
No,
I'm a to say the least.
Uh,
can you,
can you lay out why the UN,
why,
why you're so down?
I mean by,
it's,
it's a,
it's first of all,
it's a dysfunctional organization.
Um,
uh,
just as example,
I think the last two years they've ordered 21 resolutions against Israel on
human rights and only one or two resolutions.
Again,
Shane or Cuba or our venues.
So,
you know,
and the countries that are on that,
a human right committees or you know,
the bad guy.
Yeah.
It's all the bad guys and Iraq,
uh,
China,
all,
all the bad guy.
All the dictatorships.
So,
so it's,
it's a joke and,
but do you on one to impose their vision of the world on other countries and uh,
you know,
I was against recently against the,
uh,
compact on migration.
And then you'd have the,
do you want migraines to be normal?
It is not normal.
People must be able to live in their country.
We must try to bring peace and prosperity.
And that's,
that's the most important.
But no,
they want that to be normal there.
There's 215 million people that are migrants on the globe and they want to
facilitate that.
So,
and the total government saying that agreement,
but it was the worst thing.
Oh,
it's not binding.
It's not binding.
But at the end,
why signing an agreement?
And if you said that you will follow all that.
But yeah,
it's not binding,
but you will put legislation in place to be in line with the agreement that you
signed.
So that will have an effect on our country at the end.
It won't be imposed by the UN.
It will be imposed by an illegitimate,
uh,
elected Kennedy and government.
So
ironic because the Paris accord was non binding to,
and he was all about the parents.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
So I think people there,
and I think I was very clear about that and I had a lot of support about that,
that migrant a Compaq and people understand that,
you know,
we have our sovereignty as a country and we must be able to select our
immigrants.
And so that's coming from the UN.
So yes,
you're right.
Uh,
I don't like the UN.
I think that there are not so efficient and um,
and I'm clear about that.
Yeah.
Do you guys have a strain,
you know,
we're seeing in Europe now where there's nationalists parties that there does
seem to be a strain of sort of ethno nationalism or something that has a
different racial kind of cage connotation to it.
Do you guys have a strain of that in Canada?
Because it seems to me that I think what's happening and we're starting to see
it here,
is that if the,
if the good liberals and the good libertarians and the people who just want to
live and let live,
if they don't start making some advances against this radical leftism that's
moving,
there's going to be a lot of people that break in a bad way.
And in a weird way,
I wouldn't be able to blame them.
And I say that is someone that has no racism in my home,
but they would be left with no alternative as they watched their country
crumble.
Do you have any of that in Canada?
No,
we don't.
And it's a good news,
but the end,
that's why we must have this discussion and,
and uh,
I don't fear to have the discussion four meters,
no political correctness.
There's no taboo subject.
And we need to have the discussion and,
and having that discussion with Canadians,
and I think it is time to have the discussion if we wait too long,
that can happen.
Our country.
Yeah.
So,
so right now I would imagine there's probably some people on the right that are
saying,
well Bernie,
Yay.
If he gains too much strength,
it'll sort of split the right and then that gives us,
I mean this is always the argument against Libertarians,
right?
Yeah.
And I say this is someone that I voted for Gary Johnson,
you know,
and I get it the more at some micro level when the third parties,
usually the libertarian party,
that's usually gonna take from the conservatives more than the lefties.
And then then there is an argument,
then you're always going to end up with a lefty government.
I suspect as the guy leading this thing,
you don't buy that argument.
I think in the long term I don't buy that.
But actually it is the only argument that my opponent,
the Conservative Party of Canada has.
Um,
so that's their whole thing is,
oh yeah,
you vote for this guy,
you're going to fracture eyes.
They have a weak leader there.
No conviction there.
Uh,
you know,
the conservative are doing a lot of polling,
polling and focus group and survey,
but they're not doing politics by conviction.
And I'm doing politics by conviction and we must speak about what we believe
openly with passion and conviction.
And that's what I'm doing.
That's a big difference with me and Andrew Scheer and Andrew Scheer,
uh,
tried to please everybody.
And he said,
actually,
uh,
the truth,
he was with the Toronto Sun and he said,
my party,
he is a centrist,
centrist,
pragmatic politics called party open for a lot of ideas for a lot of people.
So what is saying is he doesn't have any principal,
does want to have any conviction,
doesn't have any vision for the country.
He wants to please everybody.
But at the end,
when you please everybody,
you end up pleasing nobody.
So that's their conservative.
I'm not,
I think I'm not happy with him,
but they are telling me,
Maxine,
we want to win.
And yes,
you are splitting the vote,
but I'm seeing in a democracy,
the vote,
it's always split.
If you don't want anyone to speak the vote,
it would be a dick.
Toucher you don't have so,
so why don't telling them if Andrew Scheer,
when I was with him when I was a conservative,
um,
you once,
not winning against your stent could do,
it was always six to eight points behind just thing to do.
And Maxim Biani is not with Hendry sheer right now and uh,
and we'll shoot it has not winning is bi and draw two behind your sainthood all
by four to six point now.
So he is not able to win.
So when I'm saying to people,
vote for your values vode for what you believe in,
be part of the change.
Be with us.
We have the momentum right now.
We have the real conservative policies and ideas and come with us and with,
we'll see what will happen.
Maybe we can be,
we can have the balance of power in,
in a parliamentary system.
We can be in power.
So,
I don't know.
I don't know what will happen,
but I know that we have the momentum and then so you think it's a risk worth
taking regardless.
Even if even if at the end of the day the party splits or not the market,
cause it's two separate parties but the votes are split enough that you ended up
with Trudeau.
Again,
you think it's just longterm,
it's what you have to do.
I see.
You'd have to vote for what you believe,
you know,
and and giving them another alternative.
And you know why you will vote for a politician that is telling you something
and at the end he won't do any reform me one donating because he will look at
Nepal and he won't be able to do that.
I'm speaking about real conservative reform before,
after and during an addiction time every time.
So yes,
that there's a risk over there that just stated could all be erected,
but maybe you will have,
it will be erected only as a minority government and even some minority
government.
And we are there with a lot of seeds.
We can be the difference and we can,
and Paul's our reform to the government or reverse the government.
We don't know what we can do,
but I don't know what can happen,
but I'm telling them that's a risk.
But you know,
vote,
vote for what you think will be good for this country in the long term.
That's what we're doing right now.
We did.
They liked the part.
That's why I'm telling you that's the only argument that the AV,
yeah.
Uh,
but the goal and I think I can defeat just stay into the most important from me
actually.
It's to be able to have candidates all across the country in every writing and
we'll be able to have that.
So we're not our original party where are a national body in Quebec and outside
Quebec and all across the country.
And also I'll be,
I will be present at the national debate on,
on the national TV during the,
during the election campaign in September,
October.
And that will be important for me as the leader of a new party to be there.
And I think I'll be able to questions the other leader to,
to,
to challenge them.
And that will help off party at the end.
So we can be a big surprise.
And I'm telling people,
come with us,
voted for what you believe,
be part of the change and,
and we'll be able to do something.
I don't know what would be the end result of all that,
but I can tell you that we are able to change the country for the better.
Yeah.
That,
that should be the ending.
But I'm not quite,
I'm not quite done yet.
But that was,
that was,
that was the ending portion here in a way that was your,
that was your closing stump speech there.
What do you make of,
um,
sort of the state?
We haven't talked at all about religion.
It's one of the themes that we've talked a lot about here.
And I know you're,
you're familiar with Jordan Peterson work,
um,
that it seems that the way that Western countries have,
say,
moved off of Judeo Christian values,
that they've replaced everything with a big state.
I actually don't know what you're [inaudible] actually that's,
that's I believe in that.
And then that happened in Quebec,
in my own province in Quebec at the provincial level.
You know,
we had the relationship with the state and the church in Quebec in the 1915,
1960 16 and,
and after dad,
you know,
we,
we did at the plane,
Shoulder Bala quiet revolution.
And so we were praised,
were appraised,
did the,
the church by a bigger state and that had been in Quebec.
And we're still have a big fat government at the play in Charlotte Laval in
Quebec.
That's why,
you know,
Quebec,
uh,
is a,
a poor province in Canada.
We have a kind of a formula in Canada under constitution in the,
we call that the equality nation,
uh,
formula.
The rich balances are giving money to poor provinces.
And Quebec received equitization my name for the last 50 years.
So,
so because bad economic policies have to play and show Lovell and because of a
big state at the provincial level,
because it's still work,
there's no nothing the money you ever work on.
Why did they have to do it for 50 years if this was so the good policy?
Yeah,
but Polynesian like to give them money and too,
but so,
so what you're saying about the re when I think we did that in Quebec and and at
the federal level with the total government,
they want a bigger state.
Absolutely.
So I agree with Jordan.
When is say when,
when he said that,
uh,
that was the case at the branch show Laval in Quebec and it a bit more evident
but also on the food.
I love all sorts people want,
politicians wanted bigger government and,
and the,
the,
the more bigger the garment is,
the more power the APP,
the more regulation they doing,
the more inference they will have.
And,
and so for me,
I don't buy that.
So that,
so as a libertarian and government,
which as I started,
this is an odd thing because it's the only type of people that want to scale
back the very thing they're becoming part of.
Are you worried at all that everything has become political,
that it seems politics has sort of replaced sports,
at least here in the United States.
The way we talk about politicians is the way you used to talk about athletes.
We worship these people who've never accomplished anything,
but they're good on sound bites.
Trudeau has nice hair and wears Nike socks,
although you're clearly,
you're doing all right in the sock game.
But that we,
we worship these people who should have,
if we were doing this right,
would have almost no control over us.
And yet we,
we've elevated them to some magical state that's gotta be just weird for you
personally as someone that you want to scale this thing back and yet you have to
be part of,
I have to be bothered that I have to be part of that to do that.
You absolutely right.
Uh,
but yes,
and I think that the population,
sometimes they are putting too much,
too much,
uh,
faith in a politician to change things.
You know,
and that's what I'm telling to people.
I will,
I will put forward the policies that will believe in.
But after that,
you know,
when we'll have more competition,
no more corporate welfare,
a government debt,
respect the constitution and,
and we'll all these extreme middle to good tourism policies will,
you know,
that that is there to buy votes,
ed ethnic voting and with different communities will abolish these policies.
So,
and telling them,
I'll do that,
but at the same time I'm doing that because I believe in you because I don't
want to save you for every individual problems that you can have in your life.
Uh,
I want you to be irresponsible.
That's a little be,
uh,
but you know,
and the only politician who speak like that,
and for me,
you know,
I believe in free markets.
I believe in competition,
but when you don't have competition,
it is fun,
are in politics.
And you know,
Otto politician are too afraid to say that.
And for me,
uh,
that,
that's great because I don't have a political competition on what I'm seeing.
But you're right,
you know,
people most be responsible and we must have a smaller government.
And I want,
I want to have that job to be sure to do what I want to do an LP ball in the
right way by giving them back their,
their response OBD and giving them back their own money and uh,
giving them back.
They're increasing their purchasing power.
So all the things that if they have more money in their pocket,
in their pockets that we bought,
they'll,
there'll be able to do more things.
And so for them or for their family.
So that's,
uh,
that's what I want you to do in politics.
And I like that actually.
It's my best.
I'm in politics right now.
Yeah.
All right.
I normally don't end an interview asking for favor.
Favor is this,
if you can make this thing work in Canada,
can you then send somebody down to fix the Libertarians in the United States?
Cause our libertarians needs some help.
I mean your,
your voice and someone that's speaking clarity on libertarian issues because we
have a lot of talkers that are doing it.
We have a lot of youtubers and the think tanks that do really well,
but for whatever reason,
and I,
again,
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I think he's a really nice man,
but he wasn't a great candidate.
We,
we need that.
What you are presenting,
so if you've got anybody,
can you,
can you send them our way when you're done with this name?
Don't deal.
Sounds good.
All right.
What was a pleasure?
Thank you so much for coming in and for more on Maxime you can check out
people's Party of Canada.
Dot.
Ca.